yeah what's up
what's going on tonight
hey get out the car get out
Metro Police sharing this footage with
the public showing the moments leading
up to the killing of a metro police
officer very tough moments to watch
thank you for joining us I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus we are
learning more about the moments leading
up to the deadly shootout Victoria Saha
joins us live now takes us through the
last moments of Officer Ty's life
yeah this was a press conference where
emotions were heavy as they remembered
officer TY but Metro wanting to show us
just exactly how quickly things can
escalate when responding to a call
it was a domestic disturbance call that
ended in tragedy for the Las Vegas Metro
Police Department police say a woman
called 9-1-1 because her husband
identified as 24-year-old Tyson Hampton
beat her up the victim and Mom were
waiting outside for police Hampton in
his car what's going on man videos
showing officer Tai approaching Hampton
Police say he was told to put his hands
on the wheel but then started driving
away
while firing at officer tying and
officer Gillian 18 times one of those
bullets hitting officer Ty we do know
that between officer Tai and Gillingham
12 shots were fired back at Hampton
officer Tai was rushed to Sunrise
Hospital where he died you know this is
a
tough punch for our Police Department to
take especially the men and women at the
South Central Area command who worked
with Thai I do know one thing that we're
confident of our strength and you know
we'll get back on our feet because
that's what he would want us to do but
for now it's tough this is not something
that you know any Police Department
should ever have to go through video
showing Hampton being caught by Desert
Inn and Eastern a canine brought him to
the ground police say Hampton had two
guns on him the one he used to fire it
officers was an AK-47
yeah
police say during this incident the
mother of that victim from that just
domestic disturbance call was also shot
by Hampton but she's expected to be okay
Hampton is facing numerous charges
including murder on a protective person
and four counts of attempt and murder
reporting live from Metro headquarters
Victoria Saha 8 News Now